um for me there's only three angles for
Shon
um the one we did on the Shon prep is a
m and uh then there's a UR one which is
extremely hard it's extremely hard to
uh to learn because our ego tritip mind
wants to think two-dimensionally and
that technique is not two-dimensionally
and then another one is
direct um and I don't think it's that
hard but somebody who's a
ferite they they can't find it but um
once my people learn the direct they
almost can't do the other two it's so
much better
okay uh so the the the OT one
let's just let's just do the
in
so okay so we're going to look at the
the entry then the pattern overall
pattern of each
one this is choku and
jaes
okay all right so theot the UK will be
at the North Side okay and uh they're
going this
way okay and what you're going to do
as Naga is take a 90° angle so you were
on the X and you're going to move 90° to
the line and angle of attack
okay that's what you're going to do so
you'd be at the flank of UK
okay on the UDA version it starts
exactly the same you're going to do the
same thing you were here you're going to
move to the
flank and you'd be over
here
okay and on the direct version you're
going to do the same thing
okay it always starts from the
flank okay no
difference um let me show you the two
ferite
uh we'll do the
ferite OT
and so on the ferite of m
it's really never coming in let's be
honest okay and then
uh you go this
way and you are facing that
way okay on these you're facing this way
you face the
UK
okay and then on the Ura
the UK is coming in
again
okay and you do the same
thing only you're facing the
way UK is
okay that's what you're
doing okay now the overall
pattern of the mayamot version this
one is going to
be the one Run for the
back uh outwards uh kazushi pattern okay
so UK is going to be
brought
into the spiral so let me see if if UK
is holding my right
arm
uh they're going to
do a shape like this
they're going around this
way and then we switch
sides and then they get thrown this
way okay on the Ura
pattern they're going to do
this the whole time
and on the choku pattern the choku
pattern they're going to do that pattern
again but
I do not switch
sides or I should
say
um how do I want to say
this there there's no there's not going
to be a point where I face the UK okay
but the p pattern is going to be the
same pattern is going to do this
okay and if we take these patterns again
the ferite
patterns
um they're kind of like this you go you
go so mot goes this way then a Mot goes
that
way and then you take the Ura
pattern and it goes this way and then
back that way way so you're kind of on
this line here you're on the line only
twice here you're on the line three
times
okay couple things uh in terms of
cosmological patterns obviously you see
the figure a and you see the golden
mean um if you study Silk Road you you
know this is it you know that's not it
it just can't be it
um but the reason why we end up on these
patterns is
threefold aside from just cultural a
cultural historian point of view
um one is our UK is spinally
displacing and when the UK spinally
displaced the this zigzag on a slight
angle of variation is going to hit an
opposing force and it's obvious it's a y
young Clash okay because the fedorite UK
never spinally
displaces The yyong Clash is not
Amplified enough for most of those
insensitive people to observe it in
themselves but it's there still
okay
the second reason is that is combative
experience so we know know we want to
spiral rotate every single fight you you
want to do that it helps deal with the
infinite variation that someone can
attack you with when you start spiral
rotating the fight that infinite
variation gets hugely reduced okay and
the third reason is also related to
fight
experience um there's only one opening
for
Shon and it's not where these people
think it
is I'll show you where it is in a
second but which variation you
choose is dependent upon How
deep the UK or the attacker is in that
opening um that's the variation you're
going to choose okay so um if they're
not very deep into that opening uh choku
is where it goes which is why you would
like choco choku because you don't want
them um passing
through into the closing of that opening
which is where you're down here okay so
right when the opening appears Boom the
choku entry is is right there and you
should have taken that one if they get a
little deeper into the opening that I'll
show you the Ura is the way to go and if
right before before they're starting to
come out of that opening then the option
is a m okay and these just do not
function in light of the of the opening
for sh nag
um at all and because and people think
they do because they martially don't
know where
shoag would fall into play okay so I'll
show you first the opening and then
we'll go over as best we can the entry
angles and uh these different patterns
particularly this one U because this was
the pattern in the shho Nugget prep
exercise
okay okay so the shho naget
opening um it it is a counter to a
counter that's what that's the only
place it shows up okay and if you look
at um a lot of iido Nag waza you're
throwing on the front inward
spiral well a person can counter that
especially an athletic one um by turning
around the projection point and when
they turn around the projection Point
that's where the Shon opening is okay so
first let me show you to remind you what
is the front inward uh kazushi pattern
so let's say you're going to do uh this
T there you go okay put it over here all
right so as as I drive you're going to
do the same side that's why I turned
this there you go okay as I drive and he
yields he's starting to do it let's put
this here uh I am taking that kazushi
right here is taking me around okay
we'll do it one more time and you get
any angle you need camera so that the
viewer knows exactly what we're talking
about okay okay so I finally displ he
starts to bring my body around into the
forward roll projection okay do it
again and so
if he were to throw me
boom that is the front inward
position the counter to this is that I
turn around this projection Point
here that's what opens up
sh so as he's
going and there's the Sho nugget opening
okay we do it again to show the counter
is's trying to project and not yield
around that but there is the sh nugget
opening okay one more
time
okay
um you feel you got the different angles
okay um all right
like all of AO
Kaza as I say they're like they remind
me of the way myths not myths as we
moderns use that word like a fake story
a myth is from the history of
religions is a type of narrative
technology that premodern cultures
used and they're not read the way a
newspaper article is written or the way
Mo modern literature is read um they're
not linear even if they appear to be
they're more
emblematic or
thematic um which is why they're always
accompanied by an oral tradition where
someone can explain to you uh the myth
the reason they're theat thematic is
that one piece of information is being
used to hold a bunch of information
which the elder or the Storyteller or
the shaman knows the bunch of
information it's very similar in
Japanese martial arts which is why you
need the cuden the oral tradition
because the forms are Mythic or thematic
in their holding of information and then
the teacher the Sensei knows the then
and knows
where what one piece of information is
actually talking about a bunch of
information okay so I just demonstrated
that um that someone who fights knows
where the Shaga opening is with someone
who doesn't fight thinks you're going to
manipulate someone's arm from the yeko
and they're going to be in it okay
so um as a theme then you can start from
here you see but as you start from here
you have to continue to get into that
energy and there is the
same place that we wore for the sh nag
opening okay does that make sense okay
so he's here and I am going to start to
move in a way that I get the the
Thematic opening of the Shon okay the
only difference is in
fighting his technique his energy would
be coming
around to this do you get
that okay so you kind of just like go
okay cool but I don't
have I'm going to maneuver
you I don't have this energy which is in
the technique okay
right but I do have the opportunity to
generate that energy now which I want to
do so if you give me that opening as you
counter the front inward kazushi I have
to know how to keep that energy going
into the technique so mythically
thematically that's why this thing keeps
going by this way
so I come out of the
way and then I have to have him not go
forward like Chris wants to go which is
why he loses his grip
there if you keep your grip and don't do
anything you'll feel
it it's going on this
way yes that's it
going this way yes you
see so I got to teach Chris so video
watch for a second but it's always
interesting okay
one it's going this way it's going this
way so let's go
back come
on keep
keep this way yes that's it
okay so one way that cha used to teach
the way to follow the energy is he would
do it you see and go
forward it hurts
okay but the way I do it is keep your
palm on there don't guess
anything just keep your palms it's
already
loosening
stop boom that's it all
right I'm still teaching you
Chris not going that
[Music]
way keep that that keep it I know I'm
stepping forward
Chris but it wasn't that
energy you follow your
palm Palm's going this way good
L
camera you see there's space in our
grip right there cuz you're going
forward instead of backwards
right one more time keep your palm open
your fingers now so now you're going to
open the ID fingers and they just keep
the Palm on yes you see you
see you don't use that cuz you were
relying on that Palm stays
on stay good
[Music]
now
breathe yes that's
it and I'll breathe cuz it's really
nothing there your
your egoic mind was making a bigger deal
out
here
yes
yes you I think you still have a lot lot
of tension
relax
good
yes so what I'm doing too is I'm not
shooting the energy up through his arm
cuz that's freaking him
out trying to just get him to trust so
there's my arm is not doing anything to
him
okay it's very much like
uh a horse and The Horse
Whisperer right understands that that
blanket and the
rider is like the way a cougar gets on
the back of this animal so it triggers
the horse Okay so The Horse Whisperer
kind of just starts with a ribbon on the
back then their
hand then they wipe the blanket across
do you see it's a long time before they
put the blanket on and lay it just on
there and then much longer until the
rider actually gets on in the Predator's
position on the animal okay so this is
very
similar but you have to do it so don't
make him fight you and then I'm staying
with him as much as he's staying with
me as opposed to doing the movement you
see right away I lose you because you
feel your Center being moved and not you
moving it okay all right so we're going
to work at that level but you can still
see the entry okay and that's what we're
going to look
at so you have to move where someone can
tell okay so
west east north south you're going
to you're going to move off
here is the
entry so I end up because he's finally
displacing I end up
somewhere uh around um
8:00 12:00 in front and I move off and I
am at
8:00 if he's not spinally displacing at
all don't don't move don't grip okay and
you do this don't spinally displace stay
where you are you're going to lose
connection so if you were to grab me all
right and you're here like that and he's
not spinally dising
you're going to come out of the
grip that's why this other stuff makes
sense to come in this way you see and do
the technique like
that he's not finally
displacing okay if he is finally
displacing and you want to step that
front foot over there let me just see do
it yes there you
go okay and
you're not going to get there okay so we
always require them to spinal displac
because that's where Naga is viable
against final displacement and you can't
do those other
things um an interesting thing is there
is a video on YouTube when cha Sensei at
summer camp talked about how o Sensei
told them that he fixed
shag because of
the um
counter that I just demonstrated
okay and what it was was move to here so
I'll link that video in this pose okay
so I'm moving off the line and I'm now
flanked to him
okay again we're nor my hand workk cuz
I'm working with Chris we're just
looking at the footwork and the body
work okay now from here is where you
work that opening so that technique now
you can stay where you are Chris is
remember in the opening his energy is
going this way so his body is
technically coming back at me
so that's your new angle of attack so as
his body's coming to me I move to the
other side and that is
sh and then really what it is
isida but I'm in his back okay
so right here boom in real life his
energy would be coming back this way
towards me and that's when I move out of
the
way those are the angles
okay
um do you think you got it okay thank
you all right and in case it wasn't
clear what I'm showing right now is just
the a
OT entry and then the OT pattern is what
we're doing but
um so if you look at it he comes in
going into the pattern now okay uh he
gets into this
position he's brought around stay there
please you come to this
side and this is where you have
hole it's the same po okay that's why
it's that figure a so for
example five was here come around his
leg comes
back there's his C
in the
sh his legs coming back has the energy
back back this way as in the real
counter en comes back and I came over
here and there's the same angle for
the don't use
your keep
it okay
uh the version that you're doing in your
video is not that entry nor that pattern
it is the fedorite Ura
pattern so we'll go into that now okay
and that's the one where you come
around you come
up you turn around and then now you do
that
get Chris on that same
page okay so ten
con turn and
then
hand Boom
turn okay can you do that I'll talk you
through it you're going to KN me to the
outside 10
con double pivot around and there's the
throw yes and there's the okay one more
time for
Chris
good okay now we'll add this final
displacement
so the abrupt change in Direction
because of that zigzag is not conducive
to the spinal displacement so he
needs he needs an equal y value in order
to adhere but when he goes the other way
at too sharp an angle which he
will um to the SP displacement his y
value will increase and he will lose the
adhesion so that's what's
happening right there okay what they'll
tend to do is they'll hold on to it in
shag so he's going to hold on to me you
see go ahead get start there so I push
and now the other hand is keeping me on
there
okay but it's still a young young cloud
because he has to be able to overpower
my Force output to get that to go around
okay then on top of it there's no
overall spiral of the
pairing and the opening never manifests
because the body never gets in this
position not even
mythologically okay the guys just kind
of stand in there
um so that's why we don't do it that way
I was trained that way originally but it
does it's
um and that's the UDA version so our UDA
version is entirely different from that
one which I'll show you in other videos
we'll do another video on the Ura
version and the choku version uh later
another time right now we're just
working on
theot entry and angles that were in that
video for she nugget prank